نحن في هذه الاثناء في جنوب مدينه دير
البلح حيث اغرت الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه على هذا المنزل السكني حتى
هذه اللحظات ما زالت طواقم الدفاع المدني
والمواطنون يعملون في هذه الاثناء ما زالت
الطواقم الدفاع المدني تعمل بامكانيات
ضعيفه جدا وبايديه حتى يتم استخراج هنا
اعداد من العالقين تحت انقاذ هذه البنايه
التي دمرتها الصواريخ من الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه هنا المواطنون وشهود عيان
يتحدثون بان غاره اسرائيليه
هذه المن بالاضافه الى ذان اعداد من
النازحين كانوا اي في هذه المنطقه وقد
ارتقوا شهداء بالاضافه الى اصابات وصلوا
الى مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في دير البلح قبل
قليل عندي ثلاث عندي كان نازحين استشهدت
حده امهم واولادها اثنين وجوزها قتل
اليهود اسرائيل من وين جايين
النازحين
ايش بتبحث عنان هنا مازال المواطنين تحت
انقاذ هذه البنايه يحاولون الوصول لعالقين
ولشهداء حتى هذه اللحظات لم يتمكنوا من
الوصول اليهم تحت انقاذ هذه البنايه التي
تم تدميرها عبر اطلاق عدد من الصواريخ من
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه في منطقه
جنوب دير
البلح
اط السجا السجاده ار خين خل حار زلزله
الزلزل ما عندهم رحمه ولا حاجه من خان
يونس جينا من خان يونس وجينا هنا طلعنا من
الدير هجوا من غزه ولا خلوا حاجه مدنيين
يا عمي والله مدنيين حمد غلبان طول عمره
غلبان والله غلبان
هيح مستشف اقص دكتور هي اللي اقتلوه دكتور
عالج العالج المصب
قو طول عم مش مطلوب دكتور دكتور اللي
قتلوه مش مطلوب المرض عالج كل يوم مصابين
بقم الشهداء اليوم هو استشهد طب ليش طب
ايش صار عنا احنا هو مطلوب والله ما هو
مطلوب طب اقول لك قال وهو مطلوب ماشي طب
الطفل ابو السنتين مطلوب والله ماه مطلوب
الحيوان مطلوب الحجر مطلوب الشجر مطلوب
فقدت اودي من كثر
الرماد اجت طلعت ما لقيتش اهلي ما لقيتش
لا اختي ولا اخويا ولا مراته ولا ابنه
واولاد خالي
اثنين فجاه ام فجاه واحنا بالدار ولا
تغدينا
الجمعه وقعدنا الا هم ضربونا بالثلاث
صواريخ عندكم نازحين اه عننا نازحين دار
عمي وبس ودار ودار
خالي كيف لحظه القصب كيف لحظه القصب وما
بتوصف لحظه القصب
اص ما شفت الا فوقنا الحجار والشيا
زاج بس هذا اللي شفته هنا يتم
انتشال شهيده من تحتها انقاض البنايه التي
دمرتها الطائرات الاسرائيليه قبل قليل هنا
في جنوب دير
[موسيقى]
البلح
هذا الاستهداف للنازحين
العظ قالوا لنا في الدي ماان روح دوف عطين
كنا هنعمل خيمه ونقعد ماعرفش بستنى الناس
يجوا من بعين الخير كنت قاعده عند صاحبتي
ولسه مروحه ولقيته القصر بس انا كنت طلعت
من القصر صبات شهدا ما شفتش حاجه م عرفش
حاجه ماعرفش اول مره ا الدير ماعرفش حاجه
عن الدي
اصلا كف كيف لحظه القصف صع دخان وقصف لقيت
الشصيه بتتصير وحاجات وحجار انا ماشوفتش
غير حجار وقع راسي
بس ما بعرف حاجه بعد كده ان طلعت من الدار
اصلا جتق على
راسك ايش رسالتك
اليوم عار اقوللك ايه حاله سيئه نفسي تعب
قالنا يطلعوا وضربونا برض ضربونا هقوللك
يا
خايين